[موسيقى]
حنتطرق لاربع مسببات لهاي المشكله واحد من
اهم المسببات هي الصحه السيئه بالاسنان زي
ما انتم عارفين الاسنان اذا كان فيها اي
تسوسات او اي التهابات باللثه ممكن نزيد
اعداد البكتيريا في الفم اللي بتؤدي
لزياده رائحه الفم خلال اليوم ثاني واحده
من المشاكل هي بعض انواع الطعام
والمشروبات اللي ممكن نتناولها خلال فتره
السحور او احيانا خلال وجبه الافطار واحده
من اهم هذه الانواع الطعام اللي هي فينا
نتكلم عن الثوم البصل او اي شيء فيه
سكريات زياده زي المشروبات الغازيه ثالث
مشكله اللي هي ممكن تواجهنا طبعا التدخين
التدخين مو لازم طبعا ما بدنا نحكي نوقف
التدخين نهائيا بس انه لازم نتجنبه خصوصا
خلال فتره الصخور لانه بيزيد من جفاف الفم
واللي بيؤدي لتقليل اللعاب فممكن يزيد
خلال اليوم مشكلته رائحه الفم رابع وحده
اللي هي طبعا الجفاف الفم كحاله صحيه اللي
ممكن تترافق مع بعض الادويه اللي
بنستخدمها خلال اليوم زي مثلا ادويه الضغط
او اي ادويه ثانيه ممكن تسبب الجفاف
اهم النصائح اللي ممكن اخبركم اياها طبعا
هي الاهتمام بصحه الاسنان اللي هي طبعا
نحكي التفريش على الاقل مرتين في اليوم
لمده دقيقتين او ثلاثه مع الاستخدام خيط
الاسنان على الاقل مره في اليوم طبعا فيكم
تستخدموا كمان ادوات خاصه لتنظيف اللسان
او فرشاه منفصله تستعملوها لتنظيف اللسان
ثاني شيء طبعا شرب الماء شرب الماء كتير
مهم خصوصا خلال فتره الافطار لفتره السحور
على الاقل سبع لتمان كاسات مي باليوم ثالث
شيء طبعا تجنب التدخين ورابعا واهم شيء
طبعا بدنا نحكي انه تحاولوا تتجنبوا بعض
انواع الطعام والشراب خلال فتره السحور
اللي هي تقللوا من تناول البصل الثوم
المشروبات الغازيه حتى احيانا ممكن تتجنب
واشرب القهوه لانه بتؤدي الى زياده الجفاف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات